for will basketball is literally life
[Music]
he's searching for himself through the
game and that's how he grounds himself
[Music]
that's going to resonate with so many
people
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
basketball has always been a big part of
my life i grew up playing aau it's
really important in the culture and it's
a big part of of will's journey when you
think of like the fresh prince mythology
so to speak you know we'd be remiss to
not include you know basketball we
choreographed all the basketball scenes
and it was
it was huge man it was it was it was a
lot but i was so there for it
it's not a basketball show but
basketball is part of his life therefore
we wanted to capture in a really unique
way and so for that interior you know
west philly basketball sequence i wanted
most of it to play in a winner
see will catch a body boom you know what
i mean like we see him dunk on someone
you don't really see that type of stuff
happening on tv and so once again in my
mind it's like i want to see that
[Applause]
big shout out to game changers big shout
out to lethal shooter for helping us you
know make these sequences extremely real
extremely immersive what's going on
everybody this is chris matthews a lot
of you know me as lethal shooter my job
on belair is to be the basketball tech
when there's basketball plays it's my
job to help make the plays look real
good lethal shooter chris matthews he
was a part of the process and to be able
to work with him man he is so meticulous
over the past few weeks i've been
honored to train jabari he's actually a
great athlete i've been teaching him
different things about basketball most
importantly just being himself
hey put it down
he has tight handles as you can see in
the scenes he's looking real shifty
thank you
he's a perfectionist and that's all you
can ask for is somebody to be hungry
towards the game especially as an actor
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a lot that goes into it
specifically on that court in west
philly that night that overnight shoot
was grueling man but it was beautiful i
was so happy to be there all of that
energy and the barking
you know we had to touch down in philly
we had to we didn't want to shoot
elsewhere and say oh we did an affiliate
now we had to touch down in philly thank
you all for coming out i just need y'all
to stay locked in with us once again
appreciate everyone for being here let's
go hard these six and a half hours and
let's make history together all right
it was so great to work with so many
people that were so willing to put their
all into this thing and just to see the
dedication that came into it
[Applause]
but it was a lot of work i mean this is
like one of the first scenes we see in
the og introduction and the og intro
to be able to see this play out the
intensity is there all these guys are on
point you know what i mean philly
legends out here oh man you see bigger
[Music]
it
i'm excited energy is good people is
good
this is special this is real
philadelphia magic here you want action
he just comes and gives some of the
trouble tonight we're going over the
basketball scenes it's very aggressive
the one thing we wanted to do with this
tv show is to show people real
basketball
this isn't fake we have them showing
passion we have them showing basically
angles on how to get to the basket dunks
[Applause]
morgan wanted the basketball sequence in
the show to look real you know what i
mean to be authentic and for basketball
players to look at the show and be like
oh okay i recognize that i see how he's
moving i think we landed on some really
cool basketball sequences that feel
authentic and that feel real
[Applause]
i didn't want to
you know make tv basketball i wanted to
create you know let's go further with it
go ahead will and trey
hey rashad
can you pay us in 20s
[Music]
through the game you can find yourself
and anytime will feels like he needs to
get some energy out and this is for me
too this is for me jabari i remember
there was a moment outside bar
i remember there was a moment when i was
auditioning where i was like i just need
to get this energy off i'm going to the
court and getting some shots up
just so much within the game that
translates to life and will recognizes
that
i'm gonna hit this game winning three
it's gonna be great
watch this it's next day
no cut no cuts no edits no cuts no edits
just a real deal watch this next
[Applause]
will definitely wants to go to the nba
you know what i mean i don't know if
that's in his future but
he has hoop dreams for sure
[Applause]
[Music]
now
you